Hey YouTubers, It's Charlie. Happy Super Bowl Sunday.
So we're ganna be getting a whole bunch of stuff today.
But I wanted to start with Deadpool and Ryan Reynolds.
Because he just said he wants to play Deadpool for the rest of time.
So What does that mean?
Most of you have probably learned to take what Hollywood actors say with a grain of salt,
But all this means is that they're definitely going to be working on a sequel.
Deadpool is tracking for big box office,
it was a relatively cheap movie to make as far as big superhero movies go,
Think about X-Men Apocalypse;
They have probably spent twice- maybe three times as much making that movie
and marketing it.
People are SO crazy to see Deadpool that Fox is actually spending more marketing the movie
then they spent to make it. That's how excited they are about it.
And usually that's a pretty good sign that they're ganna greenlight a sequel.
What would that sequel be?
Well, the first logical sequel would be Deadpool and Cable.
The first time Deadpool met Cable was the first time Deadpool appeared in the comics,
during New Mutants number 98.
Deadpool was hired to kill Cable
So logically they would do a version of that in the comics
Obviously they have a long relationship, they haven't always been at each others throats,
So the first time they appear on camera together
they would probably fight a little, then eventually they'd start working together.
So even if they decide to do a Deadpool vs Wolverine movie first
They can still include Easter Eggs for the first time Deadpool was hired to kill Cable,
before the story takes whatever direction they want the movie to take.
It's like Batman v. Superman,
They're ganna fight each other at first,
then they're ganna be friends and form the Justice League.
It's kinda the same thing with Deadpool and Cable.
And Deadpool and Wolverine.
Although when Cable and Wolverine are forced to work together with Deadpool
it's ALWAYS begrudgingly, they ALWAYS hate the shit out of him.
He's just the guy that wont shut up, the bugs-bunny character.
What a lot of people are quoting of the movie.
There have been advanced screenings, so people are starting to review it.
Of course, everybody loves it.
It's to be expected, it's ganna be a lot of fun,
But the other key issue that you guys need to check out if you haven't read it in a while,
It might be on Marvel Unlimited,
is Wolverine number 88 from volume 2
That's the first time Deadpool met Wolverine.
The title of that story, total bugs-bunny, 'It D-D-D Deadpool Folks'.
They meet because Wolverine goes to check on his friend, who's living with CopyCat- Deadpool's x-girlfriend.
He finds that Deadpool came back to try and get CopyCat back
but ended up trashing her place, so Wolverine gets pissed, they fight
and he gets even more pissed when he can't wound Deadpool
because of his healing factor.
So like the bug-bunny title implies
it's a total Loony Toons story, with Elmer Fudd- Wolverine trying to kill bug-bunny - Deadpool.
I love the idea of Elmer Fudd- Wolverine, that's just so beautiful.
Hugh Jackman would have so much fun.
A lot of you might have noticed that he and Ryan Rynolds are really good friends
They've been taking pictures together.
I think Fox is really happy about that.
I don't know if necessarily that Deadpool vs Wolverine would be the next Deadpool movie,
but it's totally possible.
It depends on how much longer Hugh Jackman wants to be Wolverine.
Now he could change his mind too.
Like I said, you learn to take what Hollywood actors say with a grain of salt.
Robert Downey jr. originally was going to quite being Iron Man at a certain point.
He was like "okay, I'm a little too old for this, so I'm ganna pass on the mantle on
to the next actor that Marvel wants to cast."
But why do actors like that decide to stick around?
Mostly because the studio treats them really well, the fans love it, and the movies are successful.
If the movies tank, then they'll probably be like "okay, no one wants to see me do this again.
So I'll move on."
So I think Ryan Rynolds, seeing how CRAZY people are going for Deadpool
has really jazzed him up.
Seriously, a lot of the love that you guys are feeding him is repairing the damage that Green Lantern did.
Even though actors get paid millions and millions of dollars, they still take it really personally
when people hate characters that they play.
Big big characters.
there's this story Chris Harswick told about George Clooney at ComicCon one year.
It was many many years after George Clooney had been Batman.
But Chris Hardwick said he made a little joke about Batman and Bat-nipples and
and George Clooney was like "Look dude, I just want to say that I'm sorry.
I get it, that movie was terrible. I just want to apologize  for ruining that character"
Obviously its not all his fault that that movie was terrible
But it just reminds you that even really powerful, really rich actors take it really personally
when people hate the stuff that they do.
So on the flip side of that, I feel like this Deadpool experience has made Ryan Rynolds
feel like he's 15 and just had sex for the first time again.
So he's just like "hell yeah I want to do this again!"
and the reason I'm talking about Wolverine and Cable so much
for the sequel is just because the associated with the film; the director
the producers, the actors have been mostly talking about those characters.
Cable was one of the first people they mention because Tim Miller was just like
"I feel like people would assassinate me if I didn't put Cable in the sequel."
and then everyone was like, "wait a minuet, you said sequel. Does that mean
that you're actually doing a sequel?"
Then Ryan Rynolds was like, "Hey, yeah, I totally want to play Deadpool forever."
So it's like, ok, yeah, we're probably ganna see Cable.
So I'm wondering if Cable is going to be in one of the post-credit scenes.
Now in all the advanced screenings that they did,
They actually kept some of the scenes out.
So there are a couple new post-credit scenes.
So whatever those are, we wont see them until the movie drops next week.
So I'm thinking of the two post-credit scenes;
One is Deadpool specific, it's ganna be like, Cable or something like that
and the other is X-Men specific.
Because this is part of the X-Men universe.
So we'll probably get a funny Deadpool post credit scene
where he breaks the fourth wall and does something with X-Men chacters
then we'll get a world building post-credits scene.
Where it's like: holy shit it's Cable. Holy shit it's him with characters we're ganna see in his sequel.
And no idea when they would drop a sequel if that actually ends up coming.
They'll probably wait to announce that till a little bit after the movie comes out.
If it does crazy insane they'll probably try and fast track it.
But let me know in the comments. What do you want the Deadpool sequel to be?
Deadpool vs. Wolverine or Deadpool vs. Cable?
And what do you think those two post-credit scenes are?
In related news, it's Super Bowl Sunday. There's ganna be a whole bunch of trailers.
I'll be post stuff to social all week.
Here are the links for my Twitter and Facebook.
Be sure to Subscribe to get everything.
It's ganna be really fun.
I know there's ganna be some Captain America: Civil War stuff.
I know there's ganna be some X-Men Apocalypse stuff but beyond that we'll just have to see.
Whatever ends up happening, I will totally do videos for it.
So they'll be a whole bunch of videos coming tonight and Monday.
while you guys wait for that to post you can click here for my Deadpool Kills the Super Bowl video
and my Deadpool playlist and you can click here for all my Captain America: Civil War videos.
Thank you so much for watching! Everybody lets high five! I'll see you guys tonight.
...Man he talks fast at the end don't he? Make that hard to caption, Caption Lady? Go see my movie chumps! - Love Deadpool